good
[Music]
in health has to allow the headlines
for today you can october 1st the
volcar stadium in las vegas is being
used by the organization and talent
to carry out a
blood donation event in memory of the first of
october las  people will be able to donate
blood from 9 in the morning until
7 in the afternoon they
must make an appointment and wear their mask when
entering
the city of las vegas is preparing for
a ceremony in memory of the
deceased the ceremony will be in the
egido incordien this  night in which
tribute will be paid to each life lost
during the massacre of the first of
October you can see this event online
for more information about all the
ceremonies of today visit the inss neil
dotcom diagonal in Spanish
meanwhile the metropolitan police
of the  Vegas tries to figure out if a
fatal midnight shooting was
an accident, authorities went to
a residence near Jones and
Hacienda El  wednesday night
officials said a teenage girl
had allegedly accidentally shot a young man
three people
were in the house at the time but
no one else was injured the
investigation continues
and now we move on with the weather forecast
temperatures are expected to be
above  90 degrees for this afternoon
however they will drop to 70
for tonight have a nice day and
take care of yourselves I am héctor mejía and this was
your news joe brief in
Spanish
[Music]